[Music]
well brett kavanaugh went through a lot
to get on the supreme court including
bogus charges of gang rape
but he's there and there for life or
that's what you thought
the question now is is kavanaugh's
powerful legal mind strong enough to
withstand the forces
of witchcraft it's a real question now
a coven of self-described witches in new
york is planning a rally next week
to put a hex on justice kavanaugh you
can buy a ticket to attend this hexing
ceremony for 10
bucks the quarter of that goes to
planned parenthood to help them continue
to fund their human sacrifice rituals
kathy eru is the founder of catalina
magazine she's our liberal sherpa
leading us to the snowy peaks of
american progressive thought
and she joins us tonight the rarefied
air i'm feeling dizzy
up here kathy tell us hexing
this would be kind of the latest tool in
the progressive toolbox for positive
social change
the latest tool it's it's going back
it's going backwards to uh witchcraft
we're going all the way back in our
society to the days of um
hexing and and witchcraft and yep and
spells and potions and
santeria centuries so i mean that's not
too surprising that
the party that conducts witch hunts
would also conduct witchcraft
right well it's a group actually in
brooklyn i have the information
it's going to be next week october 20th
in case any of your
viewers wanted to go um it's going to be
from 7 to 10 p.m
and everyone's uh welcome it's open to
the public and if you don't have the ten
dollars
you're still welcome to go so they're
hoping that
people who come to this hexing will then
become
activists and march and go to dc and
have their voices heard
so there's a stepping stone well it
certainly is it's a stepping stone to
some pretty dark stuff
isn't it unfair though i mean if you
want to change
the public's mind on a question
shouldn't you make your case is it fair
to engage in witchcraft against them
uh it seems that they have this um trump
anxiety disorder that um we talk so much
about that people are really kind of
um losing their minds this kavanaugh
confirmation has caused people to now
have to resort to witchcraft
and i think they truly believe this
group truly believes
that this will work and it's against
rapists also
in the united states it's not just
against kavanaugh it's against
men who they consider rapists and
they've had three hexes against trump
and they feel they were successful they
feel that the presidency isn't going as
well
so they're hoping that doesn't say so i
mean we used to laugh
at less developed nations where people
practice witchcraft and witches were
killed human sacrifice took place
cannibalism what does it tell you that
in the very heart of brooklyn
hipster hq people are doing what they do
in
you know the the most primitive places
in the world
i'm hoping i'm hoping it's a 5k run type
of thing i'm hoping it's
for awareness i'm hoping that it's so
extreme
that they're doing it as a sign of just
awareness and getting their thoughts out
there and letting it be known that they
don't support
kavanaugh um i i can't imagine
they believe that this hex will
work but um so perhaps some of them do
believe
i mean a serious question and i'm you
know i'm hardly a theologian or an
expert
right in this stuff yeah but what if
what if it's true that
not you know everything that's real we
can see and there actually are spiritual
forces and you're sitting around with a
bunch of other dumb people
summoning up dark forces like would
would you want to be in the same room
as something like that would you want to
participate in that if they're
like-minded people
and if i'm sitting with like-minded
people and these are like-minded people
and they truly do not agree with
kavanaugh being in our supreme court
and uh yeah i want to summon the dark
forces
then i can go to an event i mean it's
america there's an event for everyone
right here it is so but why wouldn't a
hex
be an act of violence against somebody
i don't know if it necessarily works
it's a it's a hex i don't think they're
necessarily going to send a
um something hurtful to him it's not
hurtful it's a peaceful gathering from
what i understand it's a peaceful hex
from what i understand it's a peaceful
hex
uh it has bad intentions but they're
like-minded people causing no one harm
wishes wishing that's like causing no
taxing people no problem at all turning
people into zombies
summoning satan to to to work his dark
magic on people they don't like not a
big deal
yeah i get it are you going by the way
i'm i don't think i'm going to go but if
your viewers would like to go
we did share the information i i don't
think i hope we didn't
i think it's the creepiest thing i've
ever heard and by the way what if it's
real i'm serious like what if this is
real you want to be around that stuff
i'd run the other way
well it's against rapists so i mean if
it's against bad guys
and it's real then it's a good thing but
against kavanaugh
nothing was proven against him yeah so i
hope that's not real
kathy ruth thank you very much